amazing to think that he coached for
another place and they didn't think he
was good enough you know and he comes
here and does a great job so it's a
great celebration for him and certainly
hard-earned well deserved and only
better than 300 301 so we'll be back at
it this week
hashtag Tommy talking about coach Bill
Belichick who got his 300th win on
Sunday New England Patriots against the
Cleveland Browns when number one
happened in 1991 when Bill Belichick was
coaching the Cleveland Browns against
the New England Patriots the Patriots
wasn't time in 1991 yes
ooh times up dick Macpherson oh I
wouldn't a guess it yeah thing but yeah
Belichick has been hanging around that
long try nine years as a head coach win
number 300 and he's on his way to the
all-time record held by Don Shula with I
believe 347 is PFT live it's a Monday
morning week 8 is in the books but for
the Steelers Dolphins Monday night game
which we will preview at some point
unless we don't I mean it's the Dolphins
the Dolphins are winless they're playing
in Pittsburgh Pittsburgh the only two
wins that you have come in primetime
still is gonna win there's your preview
there's your preview for week 8 Monday
Night Football all right at the other
end of the spectrum yeah there are two
unbeaten teams left yes the New England
Patriots and the 49ers this is the 10th
time in the Super Bowl era that multiple
teams have started seven and oo or
better in each of the last nine
instances it's happened one of those two
teams has made it to the Super Bowl that
stat comes courtesy of ESPN stats and
information so and hey you know what
I'm not gonna say it what
well they don't play each other in the
regular season Yeah right right mean
maybe they don't lose at all maybe maybe
there's gonna be an 18 and overseas 18
and oh and the Super Bowl well I doubt
that cookie talk that is kooky talk but
I mean they both have some tough games
on their schedule coming up I think
that's the big thing but I think for me
I don't know how you feel exactly you
know the Patriots are clearly the best
team in the AFC we know that the NFC I
do think the 49ers are the best team I
understand people going what about the
Saints and and the Packers I get that
but I do think that the 49ers have
shown with the way they've won
especially the last few weeks
that they're a notch above even the
Saints and the Packers at this point now
we'll see where it goes but it just it
just seems like yes it's building
towards this both teams are so dominant
on a week to week basis you know the the
Patriots are kind of doing it with their
defense and then not steamrolling you on
offense being a little more surgical
that way where the 49ers are kind of
steamrolling you on both sides of the
ball right now I think that's the
amazing thing to me their defense runs
you over and then their offense runs you
over to go with it and it would be some
Super Bowl red blue six Super Bowls
trying to go for seven ones trying to go
for six Brady in San Francisco this
one's gold this one's silver all right
we got to keep going and caught up in
the colors I think there's better
storylines let's go there's so many
opposites Jimmy Shanahan and then let's
check yep here's the thing
the 49ers if they end up with the number
one seed in the NFC yes they don't have
a home field advantage that screams out
you can't beat us Seahawks with the one
seed pencil man for the Super Bowl
Saints with the one seed but for a
horrendous call tolling that we saw last
year pencil man for the Super Bowl
the 49ers it's just it feels like
they're gonna have to earn it yeah but
they're earning it one week at a time
one at 11 to 23 has been the combined
score the last four games since the bye
week that Monday night game against the
Browns 31 to three then short week with
the Rams having a long week to get ready
for 22:7 oven now I did nothing in the
monsoon last weekend out 51 to 1351 213
is an old-school 70 style but whooping
it is yeah I remember games like that
one the talent gap between the best team
and the worst team in the NFL was
gigantic that's not the case anymore
this is a Panthers team that was four
and two and they were rested they had
two weeks to get ready for they're
feeling good about themselves and they
just got splattered by the 49ers yeah
it's it's amazing me Kyle Shanahan your
guys said that the team is getting more
confident with each win man this is this
is scary to see how would you beat how
would you even go about coming up with a
game plan regardless of execution right
how can you even come up with a way X's
and O's to beat a team like the 49ers
given what Shanahan
yeah no he's special it's wizardry you
know I mean Shanahan's the he's the
hottest plate he's you know of course
always been in the conversation for the
best play call or in football right now
he's the hottest and it's not even close
I mean they're dashing people like we
talked about early in the first hour
where we're seeing guys running for 40
yards and they're not down in to in
touch football games that's how big the
holes are and that's because of great
play design and things like that so no
you're gonna it's going to have to be a
special skill set of a defense to slow
down the 49ers it's going to have to be
a team like the Patriots who have oh we
have an amazing secondary we're not
scared of your receivers now we can do a
bunch of crap with our front seven or
eight guys to make things interesting in
your run game or you know maybe the New
Orleans Saints who are gonna be oh we
have an unbelievable front for and we're
good we can slow down that run game with
them and then we could play zone behind
it and slow down the passing game I
think the amazing thing with the 49ers
and both the Patriots is here they are
undefeated Mike and really haven't had
to like had a game where they have to
depend on their quarterback to kind of
carry them to this point right and at
some point yeah Garoppolo is gonna have
to make a big throw in a big spot to win
again right and yeah we don't right he's
capable so I mean but he doesn't had to
have that game yet this year either
where they go a we're not working very
good here Tom you gotta carry us he
hasn't had to they've been that good
right because the defense has been so
dominant but but what if the 49ers come
up against a team that takes away the
running game yeah can Garoppolo get it
tied that's the big question I don't
know if I totally feel a hundred percent
confident just saying oh yes he can get
it done
when they need him to go 28 for 35 for
380 and three touchdowns he'll do it I
know it no I don't know that yet you
know there's just there's a few plays in
every game where you scratch your head
you go how do you miss that throw or man
that was a really dumb interception
they're in a bad moment so I don't know
that's the last piece of the puzzle I
would like to see because with Brady and
the Patriots like I do know III know
that when the defense doesn't play good
and they need Brady to go 28 for 35 or
360 more times than likely he's gonna do
it and that's gonna happen with the with
the 49ers they've been so dominant they
haven't had to and I don't know what to
tell you yet Mike I just we got to kind
of wait and see that one 49ers have
their short week game this week is a
Thursday night trip to Arizona to take
on the
Cardinals that should be an easy win for
the 49ers but who knows maybe it'll be a
close game maybe maybe it'll be like
yesterday's Cardinal Saints game where
it's closed in the middle of the third
quarter and there'll be a dumb decision
that turns it the other way but I hope
it's not a blow it I want to be able to
watch the 49ers to play and face some
adversity I want to see how they deal
with a little adversity then it's
another Monday night game
the Seahawks coming right then the
Cardinals after that they got three
straight home games Seahawks Monday
night Cardinals Packers and that's when
it starts to get down yeah the Packer
hackers yeah Ravens st. Jude so there's
three teams you go they can slow down
well the Packers aren't gonna slow down
the running game I'll say that the
Ravens and Saints can so that can make
any things interesting where the Packers
I look at them and go though they can
match up good with the 49ers in this
aspect where I look at you know the
Packers pass protect really well they
can run the football they can maybe
score points against the 49ers maybe
better than other teams we've had
because they'll be able to protect
Rodgers the secondary for San Francisco
is good but I don't think the corners
are like shut down island corners like
the New England Patriots to where that
could be interesting too but both teams
have a lot of tests in front of them and
the 49ers yeah certainly gets real here
in the next few weeks I mean they've got
the two games against the Cardinals and
they've got a game against the Falcons
that you would assume
check check check yeah when when that
gets him to ten right but Seahawks twice
yeah Rams again the Rams are gonna be
ready exploding is that Sean McVeigh
Kyle Shanahan rivalry that is sneaky
great huh but but there's six games
there that are going to be tests and
they split them they go thirteen and
three is that good enough to be the
number one seed in the NFC who knows
because they've got the Saints and the
Packers the other two teams that they're
gonna be vying with for by week yeah and
for the number one seed going into the
postseason and the key is even though
they don't have a great home-field
advantage
you don't want to have to go to New
Orleans you don't want to have to go to
Green Bay go in in January you don't
want to have to go to Seattle and they
still are only I mean they have a two
game cushion over Seattle but they place
the idol twice right Seattle you know
Seattle runs the table they're winning
not not I'm not saying they will over on
the table rest the table
they will be the NFC West champions
period yeah there's a lot to be played
here at the NFC the other see is just
it's it's phenomenal I don't know what
another way to say it right now I mean
it's it's just deep and talented and
physical there's a lot of good offensive
defensive line where they can just beat
you up that way but but but the would
the the 49ers in general yes we just
have to see that last piece of the
puzzle I think they're gonna be there at
the end of the when all this is all said
and done I do think they'll be a 1 or a
2 seed but that will be dictated on the
field and it might come down to that
Packers in the Saints game just who wins
that head-to-head matchup in general but
man they they are rolling right now on
both sides of the ball them and the
Patriots are kind of established
themselves on kind of a special level
where it's those two and then there's
everybody else and not to say that
everybody this is far behind but I think
they're they're a little bit on a
different shelf right now but I almost
was gonna ask you which of these two
teams patrons and 49ers is more likely
to make it to the Super Bowl but I think
any reasonable person would say the
patriot yeah they don't the same
competition right right so the Patriots
have a tough game coming up on Sunday
night yeah we'll go ahead and start to
promote the Sunday Night Football games
or advance good Patriots at Ravens the
Ravens coached by John Harbaugh have
given the Patriots fits over the last
decade time to time with different
configurations of lineups and roster and
whatever Harbaugh has shown he can go
toe-to-toe with the Patriots and they've
got a mobile quarterback now I know
young quarterbacks have not fared well
against Bill Belichick in the Patriots
but mobile quarterbacks have and that's
gonna be a challenge down the Ravens are
coming into this one rested they're
going ready you know I remember when
they went to Kansas City earlier this
year felt like they threw everything
they could at the Chiefs to show that
they belong and I feel like they're
gonna do the same thing they're gonna
have everything they possibly can
scouring the rule book you know John
Harbaugh is still salty about that stuff
from the divisional round four years ago
it'll be five years ago in January where
the the quick substitutions and they
changed the rules after the fact and
then everything that did or didn't
happen with the flight gate after that
when the Ravens were upset they had 14
point leads twice in that game they had
the Patriots on the ropes I mean this
has this has the makings of being a
potential
great Sunday night game because if the
Ravens can beat the Patriots all of a
sudden yes it's a two-game swing you see
it tighten up 6 & 2 & 8 & 1 vs. 9 + O &
5 & 3 it has huge consequences on the
configuration of the AFC playoff field
so do you think the Ravens can beat the
pain well I think there are certain
areas where they're they're gonna give
the Patriots problems I mean at the very
least that you know the the Baltimore
Ravens secondary is gonna be able to
match up with some of the New England's
wide receivers that way where they're
gonna be able to go like oh okay hey we
can play man-to-man against this group
and feel good about our matchups and
then we can you know use the rest of our
big dudes to slow down the Patriots run
game the other side of the ball though
you know as much as I want to go ooh
yeah Lamar Jackson and running
quarterback so give the Patriots issues
what I worry about more than anything on
that side of the ball is and this will
be big for the game is Hollywood Brown
gonna play because the Patriots are
gonna put say the same thing there go
what we're not really scared of anybody
in your pass game are our corners can
match up with you guys and yeah go ahead
try to run the ball we're gonna have
eight guys by the line of scrimmage and
we're gonna have a lot of stuff going on
because they're gonna feel comfortable
about their matchups on the outside the
very least the Ravens have never been
intimidated by the Patriots Jim Hart
John Harbaugh has never been intimidated
by them and they are going to be willing
to compete and ready to fight for four
quarters that's what I expect about the
Ravens they're one of the few teams in
the AFC that does not just go oh it's
the Patriots and we're gonna be bullied
by them they try to bully the Patriots
back and at least give them respect for
that and if the Patriots get through
this one to move to none you know then
they have their bye then they have a
trip to Philadelphia for a game against
the Eagles that will not be easy that
will not be easy especially as the
Eagles continue to try to pull
themselves back into relevance then the
Cowboys yeah go to Foxborough at the
Texans on Sunday Night Football the week
after that Chiefs at the Bengals Bills
and dolphins now you know there isn't a
game that just jumps off the page and
says wow the Patriots are gonna be in
trouble they'll be favored in every game
the rest of the way right but I'd worry
about this next game Sunday night at the
Ravens well worried about that one I'd
worry about the Chiefs well I mean I
just I think the thing with the Patriots
the one thing we haven't seen that we're
okay the 49ers you question Jimmy
Garoppolo right we just haven't seen
that aspect of it yet the the Patriots I
think the one
I would just go as I don't know if
they've really played a complete
football team yet this year you know as
far as that there are opponents you know
their schedule it's it's been damn easy
there's no other way to say it's been
one of the easiest schedules in the NFL
now that the Patriots and I don't you
know I still think they're phenomenal
but you know they've been fortunate to
play teams like the Cleveland Browns who
can shoot themselves in the foot and
might have been able to compete with the
Patriots and play it close and do things
like that but it's been the Giants the
Redskins the Jets twice the Dolphins the
Steelers I mean it's been basically the
schedule of dysfunctional teams for the
most part there other than the Buffalo
Bills so we haven't seen them really
have to play battle-tested football I
guess is what I'm saying more than
anything and we thought it was going to
be the Chiefs and the Patriots down to
the wire for the number one seed in the
AFC the Chiefs are beginning to fall off
they fell off another step last night
with a loss to the Packers
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports